Julien nous inspiré pour notre passe
conso aujourd'hui on va vous donner des
conseils en avocat et là sur le plateau
pour vous donner des conseils si vous
faites avoir par un SMS frauduleux voilà
vous fait croire que votre banque vous
appelle vous demande votre numéro de
compte non mais c'est tellement bien
fait sans blague c'est ça le problème
que franchement tout le monde peut
tomber dans le panneau c'est pas c'est
pas ce qu'on
alors on a un extrait d'émission mais
c'est justement Julien courbe qui l'a
présenté
d'arnaque et vous allez voir une jeune
femme qui se fait arnaquer qui se fait
en cas on aurait pu se tomber tous pu
tomber dans le panneau
[Musique]
oui
c'est vrai semblablement une arnaque
pour lui soutirer de l'argent
alors par contre là je suis en train de
travailler si vous pouvez me rappeler un
peu plus tard mais elle est rodée elle
ne tombera pas dans le panneau
merci d'être avec nous sur ce plateau je
voulais juste donner ce chiffre 55 % des
Français affirment qu'ils sont la cible
d'arnaque au moins au moins une fois par
mois ça vous étonne ce chiffre non mais
c'est tous les jours regardez simplement
votre boîte mail et vous allez
immédiatement voir le nombre de spams
frauduleux etc aujourd'hui c'est devenu
une industrie évidemment c'est sur
Internet que les escrocs et les
arnaqueurs prouvent le plus facilement
et des appels téléphoniques etc si vous
arrivez tout le temps alors je sais pas
pour Damien moi c'est c'est quotidien
vous savez quand vous avez des enfants
donc de la CAF de d'amélie.fr de la
Poste enfin de toutes sortes de
d'institutions sérieuses et ça crée le
doute Damien aussi alors moi c'est le
compte personnel de formation si jamais
qu'on m'a proposé je peux vous assurer
que je serai incollable sur tous les
sujets c'est vrai que c'est
insupportable et c'est difficile aussi
de savoir où sont les arnaques parce que
c'est tellement bien fait qu'on a
vraiment du mal à trier le vrai faux
quoi la raison Damien maître franchement
on peut tous tomber dans le panneau
parce ils sont de plus en plus pointus
les arnaqueurs tout le monde peut tomber
dans le panneau en plus il y a des modes
il y a quelques temps c'était le compte
professionnel de formation là maintenant
ça va peut-être être autre chose vous
allez avoir des arnaques un peu à tous
ça suit aussi l'actualité parfois vous
allez avoir des arnaques en fin d'année
par exemple pour les soldes vous allez
avoir des arnaques au moment de la
rentrée peut-être pour les aides à la
rentrée etc etc et en fait
systématiquement il s'adapte ils savent
comment vous visez et puis il vous vise
en fait de mieux en mieux ils savent
avec exactement comment choisir leur
technologie évoluer un exemple vous vous
disiez tout à l'heure que les les
messages sont bien fait etc il y a quand
même énormément de messages qui sont
extrêmement stupides c'est-à-dire que
vous les lisez vous vous dites non on
veut pas tomber dans le panneau mais en
fait c'est fait exprès c'est à dire que
c'est justement parce que les messages
sont gros grains qui sont un peu un peu
ratés etc que quelqu'un qui répond ils
savent qu'ils ont réussi à harponner une
personne qui est fragile qui est faible
et qui du coup cette personne en réalité
ils vont pouvoir l'escroquer donc le
fait de faire des mauvais messages ça
fait partie de leur dispositif vous
voyez à quel point ils sont subtils
vous en avez plein à nous donner
regardez alors Tik Tok évidemment se
régale des arnaques sur les réseaux
sociaux voici un extrait que nous avons
choisi pour vous
un arnaqueur m'envoie encore un message
mais j'inverse la situation et panique
un faux goût vous avez une contravention
impayée de 35 € au plat c'était à vous
de me payer 35 € maintenant qu'est-ce
que vous racontez cliquez sur le lien
j'ai cliqué sur le lien mais ça me
demande un code de confirmation de votre
part c'est pas normal il y a pas ça
normalement votre code de confirmation
est cette 5 6 8 5 ah oui j'ai reçu ces 7
5 6 8 5 merci d'avoir souscrit à notre
offre vous serez facturé 29 euros par
mois non annuler c'est génial bon ben
voilà effectivement on adore non on
adore mon maître
sinon la première chose que vous nous
donnez comme conseil c'est de suivre son
instinct
mais en fait il y a pas mal de gens qui
justement ne suivent pas leur instinct
et qui se laisse inquiéter alors que ils
ont bien l'impression qu'il y a quelque
chose qui va pas et donc ils sont là
c'est bizarre ça va pas mais il répond
quand même et ça ça arrive à tout le
monde notamment là sur l'exemple de
l'amende vous recevez une annonce d'une
amende ah bah même si ça a l'air un peu
bizarre parce que très sincèrement c'est
assez rare de se revoir une annonce
d'une amende comme ça en général doit
recevait plutôt par la poste vous avez
le papier qui va bien etc et puis les
indications de comment la congester si
vous le souhaitez donc vous allez avoir
un truc derrière vous qui vous dit ah
mais non mais en fait c'est bizarre bah
si c'est bizarre peut-être par les
entours de vous voyez demandez à
quelqu'un mais qu'est-ce que c'est ou
tout simplement et bien aller à vos
impôts pour garder ce qu'il en est en
général c'est ce genre de choses qui est
faire donc il faut croire en son instant
il faut pas se laisser si vous dessinez
si vous avez l'impression qu'il y a
quelque chose qui va pas c'est sans
doute qu'il y a quelque chose qui va pas
alors ne fait pas trop confiance à votre
instance
exactement ça le souci c'est que parfois
ça va être l'inverse vous allez croire
que en réalité et bien en fait c'est pas
important etc alors qu'en fait ça l'est
et ça ça arrive souvent si vous voulez
quand vous êtes pris dans une situation
d'urgence typiquement quand vous avez le
l'appel du fauconseiller bancaire ah oui
ça c'est horrible et les gens qui sont
victimes d'appel au fauconseillé
bancaire c'est terrible parce que ils
ont vachement d'informations excusez-moi
mais ils ont beaucoup d'informations
c'est très déstabilisant pas tant que ça
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que c'est
surtout surtout des gens qui savent
parler donc ils vont faire un appel deux
appels 10 appels dans la journée et puis
ils vont tomber sur quelqu'un qui a
envie de parler et qui a envie de le
raconter des choses qui a envie
justement de se dévoiler un peu qu'on a
besoin là sur le moment sur l'instant et
ça va passer et donc en fait il faut
aussi parfois remettre un petit peu des
formes et donc si vous voulez surtout
quand c'est la première fois qu'on vous
contacte parce que bon euh en général
typiquement l'arnaque au fauconseiller
bancaire bah votre conseiller vous
échangez avec lui avec la messagerie
sécurisée de votre banque ou bien vous
allez sur place plutôt d'un coup vous
recevez un message WhatsApp de votre
conseiller bancaire puis c'est pas le
même c'est la première fois quand c'est
la première fois il faut remettre un peu
de formalisme et il faut pas hésiter à
dire quel que soit la situation
d'urgence à dire attendez mais vous
savez quoi je vous rappelle je vais
vérifier et allez se renseigner allez
justement à la banque aller à
l'organisme qui émetteur du message mais
il faut savoir dire stop attendez et
remettre un petit peu de formalisme
c'est très très très important
troisième troisième conseil sinon c'est
dehors
ça a l'air simple mais c'est très
difficile
à parler etc et les banques par exemple
n'arrêtent pas de le répéter on ne
voudra jamais votre numéro de carte
bleue par téléphone sauf que de temps en
temps excusez-moi mais ça arrive quand
même il y a quand même des situations
avec certains magasins avec certains
vendeurs ou ben oui on doit le faire
donc en fait c'est pas si vrai que ça et
donc ils savent créer la situation mais
surtout et c'est toujours la même chose
il y a pas d'urgence l'urgence c'est
jamais à 20 minutes près vous avez un
conseiller qui vous appelle qui dit il y
a une fraude là il y a quelqu'un qui a
des enfin qui a pris 12000 euros sur
votre compte bancaire alors il faut
réagir maintenant donnez-moi votre code
vous dites vous savez quoi je vous
rappelle dans 30 minutes donnez-moi
votre numéro je vous rappelle et vous
prenez ces 30 minutes pour vérifier
c'est super important quoi qu'il arrive
une banque par exemple si elle doit
annuler quelque chose c'est pas un délai
de 30 minutes de toute façon ça va être
un délai de quelques jours ou de
quelques heures donc vous avez le temps
donc vous mettez ce temps et vous vous
taisez et vous ne donnez pas
d'informations pas vous donnez pas votre
sur le côté pas pas votre doigt de
naissance sur la connaît pas et au pire
vous dites aux gens j'ai pas envie d'en
parler par téléphone ou je veux pas vous
répondre sur le chat où je vous
répondrai pas par email et je préfère
voir quelqu'un vous pouvez toujours
demander à avoir un conseiller c'est
possible pour la banque je vous
l'accorde mettre mais néanmoins il
existe des situations d'urgence qui sont
parfaitement légales ou on vous demande
de payer dans l'instant dans dans
l'instantané par exemple les amandes les
amandes quand vous recevez un courrier
de la part de la police qui vous indique
qu'il faut que vous payez sous 8 jours
sinon on vient saisir vos meubles là
c'est une urgence c'est par courrier je
vous l'accorde et surtout surtout huit
jours c'est pas 30 minutes c'est pas 30
minutes c'est-à-dire que justement vous
avez le temps de vérifier la réalité de
l'amende et et c'est toujours comme ça
c'est-à-dire qu'on est bien sûr il y a
des urgences mais une urgence il faut
s'entendre il y a l'urgence qui est de
quelques jours de quelques heures puis à
l'urgence de la personne au téléphone
lui et pas dans l'urgence de quelques
jours quelques heures ils veulent votre
code là maintenant parce qu'il sait que
si vous raccrochez et que vous vérifiez
c'est fini il l'aura jamais et donc il
va tout faire pour réussir à vous le
faire dire pour avoir votre date de
naissance pour avoir les trois chiffres
de votre carte bleue pour avoir ce ou
quoi qu'il a envie d'avoir de toute
façon le mot de passe de votre boîte
mail vous pouvez pas imaginer à quel
point c'est varié et il y a tellement de
choses possibles donc la règle c'est de
se taire comme quand on est en garde à
vue on se tait exactement elle est pas
fou Michel Drucker je crois éternel de
10000 €, il a communiqué là-dessus il a
raconté ce qu'il est arrivé mais
rappelez-vous c'était je crois Jean-Yves
Le Drian qui avait été arnaqué par une
arnaque au président avec des gens qui
avaient fait une visio avec lui en
imprimant un faux masque en latex pour
qu'il croit qu'il était face à quelqu'un
qui connaissait alors que c'était pas le
cas donc c'est vous dire ça peut aller
très très loin est-ce que si je me fais
arnaquer demain parce que je tombe dans
le panneau parce que c'est parfois très
bien fait
apprenez à utiliser vos assurances et
votre cinquième conseil ben oui en fait
ce qui va se passer c'est que la plupart
des gens ne savent pas qu'ils ont des
protections juridiques des assurances
dans les petites lignes de votre carte
bleue ce genre de chose vous pouvez les
contacter parfois les assurances
protection juridiques vous savez vous
vous avez un numéro de téléphone vous
les appelez vous leur demandez qu'est-ce
qu'il en est ce que c'est vrai est-ce
que c'est faux ils vont pouvoir vous
aider et puis il y a pas que ça il y a
aussi tous les professionnels qui
existent bien sûr il y a les avocats
mais vous avez aussi les comptables les
notaires vous pouvez aller voir au pire
vous savez quoi vous allez au
commissariat vous avez tout bêtement au
commissariat vous leur montrez
typiquement pour les faux avis d'amandes
ou ce genre de choses vous leur dites ça
c'est vrai ou c'est faux ils vont
prendre 5 minutes ils vont vous répondre
bien sûr même à la mairie vous avez
aussi des associations qui peuvent vous
aider il faut faire attention à ça et il
faut aller chercher de l'aide là où elle
est
en ayant été attentif à se taire avant
ce qui est bien si vous avez donné
toutes les infos sur votre compte
bancaire en amont il est vidé et là ça
va être compliqué
juste quelques jours mais vous avez des
gens qui sont en Afrique on typiquement
tout ce qui est les brouteurs etc qui
démarchent non pas pour des histoires de
compte bancaires enfin si c'est toujours
du compte bancaire à la fin mais qui
démarche sur les sites de rencontres sur
Facebook etc vous avez en fait vous avez
des gens absolument partout vous avez
des Russes vous avez aussi des arnaques
à la fosse webcam pornographiques
en disant attention on a des on a activé
la caméra de votre téléphone ou votre
ordinateur et on vous assure regarder
des films pornographiques ce genre de
choses si vous voulez en fait il y a des
Russes qui font ça il y a des en fait ça
touche tout le monde c'est ça pourquoi
parce que
c'est sûr d'arnaque et le problème c'est
que ça marche le problème c'est que ça
marche et qu'en fait c'est ça la
difficulté c'est que vous arrivez
toujours dans le nombre à tomber sur une
personne en situation de fragilité
quelqu'un qui est voilà qui sait qu'il
faut se taire mais là sur le moment bah
en fait elle va dire des choses et c'est
ça qui est malheureux c'est que
finalement dans le nombre on arrive à
trouver des gens qui vont se faire
escroquer bon vous dites aussi ne
laissez pas vos proches seule face au
numérique s'ils sont passées
c'est le conseil le plus important mais
pas que les aînés c'est aussi regarder
si vous êtes parents vous laissez pas
vos enfants seul face aux réseaux
sociaux bon mais si vous savez que votre
grand-père votre grand-mère ou même vos
parents sont pas à l'aise peut-être avec
Tik Tok ou des choses comme ça
expliquez-leur faites attention à ce
qu'ils font dites-leur quand c'est une
arnaque et surtout il faut faire
attention il faut pas qu'il y ait de
honte c'est à dire qu'il faut éviter
quand quelqu'un vous pose une question
sur une arnaque de se moquer de lui il
faut bien se dire non mais attention ça
peut arriver à tout le monde et donc il
faut dire ah bah tu sais quoi et
expliquer un petit peu en fait c'est une
arnaque parce que ceci parce que cela il
faut surveiller et s'en parler un petit
peu les uns les autres ça marche très
bien et en fait c'est la meilleure façon
de se protéger c'est d'avoir autour de
soi des gens qui connaissent un petit
peu qui soit plus jeune un peu plus âgés
ou alors si on est un peu isolé bien
d'aller chercher des associations qui
vont vous aider pour le faire mettre
deux minutes
pour info qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez faire non non c'est pas mais
si jamais effectivement non non mais la
fausse avant si on se fait avoir malgré
toutes les mesures de précaution quels
sont nos recours il nous reste 2 minutes
30 mais c'est un conseil que c'est c'est
c'est c'était à mon avis un point c'est
important n'hésitez pas à porter plainte
mais c'est pas compliqué d'abord c'est
gratuit hein c'est important à dire en
fait parler par Internet justement
facilement ça dépend vous pouvez vous
pouvez aller sur farose et cetera mais
pour beaucoup de gens je pense que le
surtout des gens qui sont mal à l'aise
avec internet leur demander de porter
plainte par internet c'est un peu
contradictoire donc aller au
commissariat ils sont là pour ça les les
forces de l'ordre sont formés parfois
ils sont un peu débordés moi-même vous
voyez là je me suis fait voler un
téléphone il y a quelques jours je vais
devoir aller à mon commissariat pour
porter plainte je vais pouvoir rooter
pendant quelques minutes peut-être une
heure ou deux et je vais faire ma
plainte faites-le et vous savez pourquoi
il faut le faire parce que vous êtes
probablement pas seul à vous être fait
arnaquer il y a sans doute d'autres
personnes qui sont faites arnaquer je
vous ai dit il y a quelqu'un là qui
s'est fait arrêter il y a quelques jours
donc en fait on retrouve des gens et
peut-être que vous allez pas récupérer
c'est compliqué de veut dire que vous
allez être indemnisé ou que vous allez
réussir à récupérer ce qui vous a été
volé c'est une chose mais au moins on va
pouvoir mettre fin à une série d'arnaque
et d'autres gens ne seront pas arnaqués
et parfois on peut récupérer ce qui vous
a été pris ça peut arriver c'est
important
ça peut arriver que les policiers disent
être sûr une plainte ou plus pas plutôt
une main courante et c'est très
important parce que si jamais vous devez
déclencher des assurances de toute façon
elles vont vous demander d'avoir porté
plainte il y a toujours des délais qui
sont obligatoires pour déposer votre
plainte je vous parlais mon téléphone
portable moi-même voyez j'ai 8 jours
pour déposer ma plainte bon ben voilà il
faut que je le fasse avant que les 8
jours soient écoulés donc porter plainte
le commissariat on l'habitude ils sont
formés à ça ils savent ce dont il s'agit
ils vont ça rentre dans leur case ils
vont faire c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça et la plante sera faite donc
allez-y n'hésitez pas faites-le ça mange
pas de pain et derrière les policiers
feront leur travail avec un peu de
chance ils vont retrouver des personnes
ils vont mettre fin au système et
peut-être même pour réussir ez à
récupérer ce qui vous a été prises à
contacter aussi vos assurances mais
voilà soyez prudent de donner aucune
information ni votre nom votre numéro de
compte on le répète mais c'est vrai que
ça peut arriver à tout le monde ils sont
de plus en plus malins ces arnaqueurs
merci beaucoup maître d'être venu sur ce
plateau merci Ludivine merci
on a passé un très bon moment comme
toujours avec vous à tout de suite c'est
pa